un retrait de près de 12 mille soldats
américains du territoire allemand
celle annonces du chef du pentagone
marque espère qui évoque un plan
stratégique et une opération de
dissuasion vis-à-vis de la russie
il prévoit de reconduire ces militaires
dans d'autres pays de l'otan comme la
belgique ou l'italie
près de 2000 soldats devraient être
répartis entre rome et bruxelles les
pays baltes ainsi que la pologne sous
réserve d'accord devrait aussi être des
destinations d'une partie de ses troupes
en raison de leur proximité frontalière
avec la russie le projet actuel de le
com va redéployer environ 11 milles 900
militaires basés en allemagne
l'effectif passant d'environ trente six
mille à 24000 de manière à renforcer
l'otan à accroître la dissuasion
vis-à-vis de la russie et à concrétiser
les autres principes énoncés sur les
1900 militaires près de 5600 seront
propositio née dans les pays de l'otan
et environs 6400 retourneront aux états
unis mais c'est un autre son de cloche
du côté de donald trump
le président américain estime que
l'allemagne ne participe pas à ces halos
tant d'un point de vue financier et se
dit prêt à revenir sur ce retrait si les
allemands étaient enclins à participer
davantage
ils sont là pour protéger l'europe
ils sont là pour protéger l'allemagne
n'est ce pas l'allemagne est censée
payer pour cela et elle ne paye pas
alors pourquoi devrions nous les laisser
nous ne voulons plus être les pigeons
les états unis ont été exploitées
pendant 25 ans tant sur le plan
commercial que militaire nous protégeons
l'allemagne nous réduisant donc la force
parce qu'il ne vais pas leur facture
c'est très simple ils sont des
délinquants
ce retrait aurait un impact certain sur
plusieurs villes allemandes
l'allemagne qui craint que cette
décision affaiblit ce l'otan on attend
les contours et malgré l' annonce aucun
retrait massif n'est prévue dans
l'immédiat
notre ministre a parlé à son collègue
américain en cours de nombreuses autres
réunions notamment au sujet du plan
américain visant à réduire à terme le
nombre de troupes ici ainsi des
procédures ont été discutés ils en ont
été informés les chiffres que nous ont
déjà été communiqués approximativement
mais comme vous pouvez l'imaginer il y a
encore beaucoup de détails à éclaircir
et nous devons les attendre ainsi les
effectifs militaires américains en
allemagne devrait passer de 36 milles à
24 milles cet épisode pourrait accentuer
les dissensions au sein de l'otan et
déclenché de nouvelles tensions